I'm here at Google Cloud next 2023 on
the floor with Kent Hua Global gke
Solutions manager here to talk to us a
little bit about gke optimization I
think the most fun part is being a hair
next with our customers and I think one
of the key things is to talk about
optimization but the key thing here is I
can optimize all I want but I need to
factor in reliability as a result of it
if my workloads are not as responsive as
I want it to be that can be impactful
with my brand even if I'm trying to cut
costs running a cost optimized gke
cluster is only worthwhile if your
workloads are also reliable so what's
the first thing you can do you can set
your kubernetes requests for your
workloads this is for resources like CPU
and memory so the kubernetes knows what
to do with them and can allocate them
the resources they need to be reliable